from more murderous games we never got
to see to alternate costumes characters
and casting squid game was almost
completely different yupikai movie
lovers i'm jan and in this video i'm
revealing everything that was deleted
cut or changed in the final version of
squid game obviously spoilers ahead so
take care
when the show's creator first came up
with a concept for squid game back in
2008 he wanted to make a feature-length
movie not a tv series the original
script was for a two-hour film and
although it mainly concentrated on the
games rather than the relationships
between characters and their backstories
there still wasn't enough screen time to
cover all the games we see in the show
today in fact even when it came to the
netflix series there was still a whole
bunch of korean children's games they
considered including but that ended up
getting the chop for instance there's
gongy which consists of throwing into
the air catching and picking up pebbles
or other small objects not only is it
popular in korea but it's also found in
countries around the world under a
variety of names including knuckle bones
or jacks another game the creator almost
included but decided to cut was a game
based on a korean nursery rhyme that's
similar to oranges and lemons or london
bridges falling down where children form
arches or gates with their arms which
they drop to catch players walking
underneath as the song finishes i can
imagine the horrific twist the show
might have added to this game given how
the nursery rhyme ending of oranges and
lemons is a chopper coming to chop off
your head a team game that almost made
it into the series was why did you come
to my house where players hold hands in
two lines and advance on each other
trying to win players from the other
side over to their own it's a bit like
the game red rover but the korean
version also involves a song and rock
paper scissors originally instead of the
red and blue tile game that the salesman
plays with gyun the show's creator
thought they should play a kind of
knitting game called cat's cradle it's a
game where the players create string
figures between their fingers and he
thought it would be funny to see two men
doing that however he said he gave up on
the idea as the rules wouldn't be
understood globally elastics or jump
rope was also suggested but he felt that
didn't work in terms of excitement and
tension and was a little difficult for
everyone when it came to explaining all
the rules by the way gongy and elastics
did at least get a shout out in the show
when gion was speculating what game they
might play next
the distinctive costumes worn by the
characters are a crucial part of the
highly stylized series but originally
its creator wanted a completely
different look for the game's workers
which would have given them more of a
boy scout vibe now i can see where he
was coming from with that idea as boy
scouts are associated with childhood and
the whole show from its games to its
sets emphasizes the irony of grown-ups
playing kids games but with very adult
consequences however scout outfits
wouldn't have given the workers the same
degree of anonymity and they also
wouldn't have given them the sense of
being ants in an ant colony that the
director was looking for the show's art
director also went through numerous
takes on the worker's mask including
animal designs before arriving at the
final fencing inspired mask with lines
reminiscent of an ant's face the
ultimate design of hot pink hooded
jumpsuits with black masks has proven
hugely popular around the world with
store-bought versions selling like
hotcakes or should that be honeycombs
and becoming a top choice for halloween
some of the most heartbreaking moments
in the marbles game were originally
going to be very different in the early
days of squid game's development as a
movie g young as we know her didn't
exist and rather than a young woman
who'd been imprisoned for killing her
abusive father in her place was a male
character however 10 years later when
writer director wang dong-yuk came to
adapt his original idea for tv he
decided to create a female character
instead as he wanted to develop a bond
between her and north korean defector
sebioc and highlight two people who
weren't fighting and killing each other
to climb up despite their gut-wrenching
life or death situation the scenes
between jiyong and her partner in the
marbles game with all their empathy and
understanding are among the most
powerful and touching moments in the
series and have had viewers the world
over in tears in fact just reading the
script for that episode had the actress
who played stabiliuk sobbing her heart
out and as far as the show's creator is
concerned those two characters are in a
way the most innocent people and ji
young sacrificing herself so sabiak can
reunite with her family is the scene
that makes you cry the most
another fan favorite performance we
almost missed out on was anu
pomtrapati's portrayal of pakistani
migrant worker ali abdul who ends up in
the games as he can't support his family
after his boss repeatedly refuses to pay
his wages although ali is played
beautifully by trapati apparently he
wasn't the original choice for the role
that was actually filipino actor carlo
aquino who the show's creator invited to
audition after seeing him in a filipino
movie but despite being offered the part
of ali sadly for aquino covered 19
restrictions prevented him from
traveling to korea for the shoot so the
production looked at foreign performers
already in the country which is how
indian actor trapati who moved there 11
years ago got his chance to impress the
team with his emotional acting and
fluency in korean three auditions later
he got his big breakthrough and went on
to capture the hearts of millions with
his take on the kind and selfless ali
leaving many of us crying our eyes out
during his heart-rending final scenes by
the way another filipino actor christian
legahed also auditioned for ali but
while his acting was good they were
worried he wasn't fluent enough in
korean he did still end up in the show
though as player 276 who you can spot
taking part in the tug of war on gn's
team
as if having to play and win kids games
to stay alive wasn't bad enough the
players also have to contend with the
murderous bully doksu and his gang
including con artist migno who
interestingly enough weren't in the
original script for squid games
according to the show's creator he added
them to the netflix series as he wanted
a villain character to escalate conflict
in the initial movie script there was no
sign of policeman jun ho who in the
series poses as a worker to infiltrate
the games and find his missing brother
jun ho ends up being a crucial part of
the story as he gives viewers a
backstage pass to life behind the scenes
for both the workers and the vips thank
goodness then the show's creator was
able to add his character and storyline
once he had lots of extra screen time to
play with adapting his film idea for tv
combined with its eye-catching artwork
squid game is such an attention-grabbing
title for the show that it's hard to
imagine anyone ever thinking of calling
it anything else but in 2019 when
netflix first announced that they were
producing the series it had a totally
different name back then it was called
round six after the number of games
played according to min young kim the
netflix executive of the region that
name came about because they wanted the
show to appeal to audiences everywhere
and were worried not enough people would
get the title squid game what an odd
name as even in korea where it's a real
children's game apparently it's not well
known to every generation so initially
they thought the more general name round
six would help people understand what
the series was about fortunately the
writer director later steered them back
to his original title as it's a unique
show and that game is the essence of it
even worse than a title change for many
people though would have been if the
show had never been made and for a long
time that was a very real probability as
all the korean studios that creator wang
pitched his idea to back in 2008-9
thought that the whole concept was too
grotesque and unrealistic so finding
investors and actors for his script
which at the time was for a two-hour
movie proved impossible a decade later
however the show's writer-director says
that sadly the world has changed into a
place where such an unbelievable
survival story fits well and he added
that some elements even seem realistic
now that so many people are interested
in fast making money schemes and on top
of that the pandemic has exacerbated the
disparity between rich and poor in fact
he actually came up with the original
idea after the global financial crisis
of 2008 when three generations of his
own family were struggling for money and
living on loans after his mother retired
and a film he was working on fell
through indeed things were so bad that
at one point he had to stop writing the
script as he needed to sell his laptop
for cash a breakthrough came though in
2018 when he took his idea to netflix
who'd just recently opened an office in
seoul and they snapped up the project
suggesting they worked together to turn
it into a series as they felt there was
much more to the story than could be
contained in one movie a lot of hard
work later and squid game became south
korea's first series to reach netflix's
number one spot in the us and around the
world and the show's just full of
incredible details in the set design
plus tons of sneaky easter eggs and
foreshadowing for all the characters
which i discuss in lots more depth in my
things you missed video tap here to
watch that or follow the link in the
video description so are there any games
or things you'd like to see in season 2
of squid game let me know in the
comments below and if you enjoyed this
then a thumbs up and a share are hugely
appreciated tap left for my full squid
game playlist including amazing
improvised moments that change the show
thanks for watching and see you next
time yupikai movie lovers